我聽說今年(2025年)4月
台灣有一個
40歲左右的工程師
在一家半導體公司在工作
休假的時候
他很認真還回去加班
收假的時候
竟然的被同事們發現
他在無塵室裡面
猝死了
聽起來很難過
對 你每天拚命賺錢
卻忘了身體
才是你的本錢
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要特別分享給
三餐不正常 輪班族
長期過勞的科技人
或是上班族
我會教你簡單的方法
幫你找回健康
還沒訂閱的人趕快訂閱
把這一集分享給你身邊
很努力工作的好朋友們喔
三餐不正常胃悶痛
1招養好脾胃
年薪百萬的科技人啊
身體最常出現
這三大危機
吃不好 睡不好 壓力大
最常見的就是胃不好
出現的小毛病
胃食道逆流 胃潰瘍
甚至脹氣 便秘
來 想養好脾胃
我跟你說一個簡單的方法
你每天上班前
幫自己準備好食物
沒時間煮的人
你可以去超商買地瓜
茶葉蛋 蒸玉米
或是一瓶豆漿
比較有時間的人
你用電鍋燉好
四神湯 小米粥
放在燜燒罐裡
這兩道
都能養護你的脾胃
趁工作有空檔
趕緊吃那麼一口吧
我再說一次
工作再忙也不能不吃
就算只是吃幾口食物
都比你空腹
讓胃酸一直分泌
要來得好喔
胃常常悶痛的人
來按這個穴
它叫做內關穴
在手腕的橫紋
往上三個指頭
在這個兩個筋的中間
按壓一兩分鐘
這個穴可以舒緩
胃痛 胃脹和噁心反胃
是啊 胃如果顧得好
人生是彩色的啦
脾胃一壞喔
整組都壞掉了
全身都出問題
很多慢性病
都是從脾胃失調而來
別小看
沒時間吃飯的代價
空腹太久
胃酸一直刺激黏膜
先是胃悶痛
再變成胃食道逆流
加上你是常常
吃飯吃太快的人
你就成功的把脾胃弄壞掉
輪夜班睡不好
喝1茶護肝降傷害
科技業工程師最怕的
不只是加班趕進度
而是日班 小夜 大夜輪不停
還要隨時On Call
作息很亂
身體就像電腦
一直沒有關機
久了你就會遇到三個東西
自律神經失調 三高
還有傷了肝
第一個 自律神經失調
長期的作息混亂
交感神經好像按了
快轉的按鈕
心跳加快 腦子停不下來
結果就是睡不著
睡不好怎麼辦
你先按一按
你先按一按神門穴
神門穴在哪個地方呢
它是在手腕的橫紋上
在小指跟無名指之間的
這一條線上
睡前按壓左手右手
左手 右手這樣
各按它個
一兩分鐘
幫你舒緩緊張 更快入睡
輪班族最容易
白天想睡
晚上卻很清醒
他免疫系統
代謝都全往下掉了
想讓自己舒服一點
你可以用光來提醒身體
補眠的時候
房間一定要暗
夠暗才行
拉上窗簾或者戴個眼罩
讓身體知道
現在是晚上不是白天
褪黑激素才會開始分泌
醒來以後
不管什麼時間
一定要接觸光線
例如曬曬太陽
告訴大腦現在是白天
讓身體找回正常的節奏
睡不好還會引發更大的問題
血壓 血糖 血脂肪都會飆高
甚至於還傷到肝
新竹有一位肝膽腸胃科醫生
他說他的慢性肝炎病人裡頭
有一半是科學園區輪班的工作人員
他們只要
輪班或者超時工作
肝功能指數
就開始瞬間的往上飆升
這就是爆肝的警告了
別讓輪班透支你的肝
來喝一杯
枸杞菊花茶
養肝顧眼睛
枸杞裡的枸杞多醣
能夠穩定血糖
菊花能降火氣 降血壓
讓血管更健康
降低輪班的問題
長時間憋尿
1茶飲護腎防泌尿科病
年輕的工程師
在實驗室裡頭工作
因為防塵衣穿脫不方便
可能半天整天都穿著
連上廁所的時間都變少了
有工程師說他
一天只喝兩杯水
一杯中午吃完飯後喝
一杯下班前喝
整天下來他只上了兩次廁所
長期這樣做
就是腎臟泌尿系統
出大問題的候選人了
我們一般人的排尿量
是每兩個小時一次
一天大概會上7到8次廁所
而他只上了
兩次
那就太少了
尿液在膀胱裡滯留太久
容易造成尿道膀胱的發炎
嚴重的就可能出現
血尿
這種情況小編說是
職災啦
所謂的職業災害
對呀 像美髮師
警察 醫生
也會遇到這樣的問題
不錯 我們當醫生的都知道
就是有的時候長期的
不能夠趕快起來上廁所
科技人或主管們
別只顧賺錢
身體弄壞了
要想保養好泌尿道
很簡單
我教你兩招
第一 泌尿道不舒服的人
來喝一杯白茅根茶
白茅根能清熱利尿
舒緩泌尿道的不適應
白茅根怎麼喝
你準備一兩的白茅根
到藥房去買
清洗乾淨以後
用1000cc的水來煮
煮滾之後轉小火
繼續煮大概20分鐘
就可以喝了
沒有空煮的人
可以用馬克杯
用熱水沖下去
對 常常要熬夜加班
壓力大的人
你可以在辦公室裡
用熱水燜泡著這樣喝
提醒你
兩種人不要喝
體質虛寒
那些吹一點風就怕冷的人
還有月經期間的人不要喝
第二就是
口渴了要喝水
想上廁所不要憋著
千萬不要憋尿
這是保護泌尿道
最好的方法
24小時on call
工作壓力大
1呼吸法快速放鬆
如何克服壓力
壓力不會自己消失
但你可以學習暫時把它放掉
來推薦你一個
很好用的呼吸法
它叫做緊張消除呼吸法
做法非常簡單
鼻子吸氣3秒
再從嘴巴吐氣6秒排出來
也有人把它叫做
1:2 呼吸法
美麗的太太
我們來感受一下
這個呼吸法好嗎
好啊
來 我們先
吸氣三秒
再嘴巴吐氣六秒
再吸氣三秒
嘴巴吐氣六秒
我們現在做一做看
吸23
呼23456
你做這一種呼吸法的時候
吐氣要慢慢的吐
像拉長的絲線一樣
把壓力一點一點的釋放
美麗的太太
剛才覺得效果怎麼樣
不錯啊
感覺很輕鬆
感覺輕鬆了很多是吧
好
你在辦公室 捷運上
甚至在睡前做
都能讓你舒緩焦慮和緊張
很方便的
這個呼吸法是來自日本
自律神經研究權威
叫小林弘幸教授
它能活化你的副交感神經
並且增加血液循環
讓氧氣順利送到
全身各個角落
肌肉自然放鬆
緊繃的感覺就會逐漸消失
賺錢卻丟了性命
這樣做找回健康
前幾年在科學園區
發生過一件事
一個財務副總
在連續加班之後
心肌梗塞最後成了植物人
他本身就有高血壓
甚至曾經在公司
已經昏倒過兩次
真正的發病的時候
才四十多歲
正是壯年
可以做最多事的時候
樹根要是穩固
就不怕樹梢被颱風吹襲
你應該先把自己照顧好
才能安然的
面對生活的風雨
你曾經想過
人為什麼
過度賣命會生病嗎
中醫講
天人合一
人的作息 臟腑的運行
其實是要遵循
自然的節律生活的
我們每一個人
都只有24小時
太陽升的時候
就該起來上班工作對不對
太陽下山的時候
就應該要休息
該要睡覺的時候就去睡
該醒的時候就醒
這個可以說是
老天爺安排的
身體固定的規律
如果你違背了
會發生什麼事
身體就開始跟你抗議了
生病 腫瘤 癌症
什麼都來跟你糾纏
搞得你痛不欲生
也不一定
我再說一次
奉勸各位
不要再糟蹋你的身體了
努力工作值得讚許
但是你長期的這樣糟蹋
濫用你的身體
可就不是一個
負責任的行為了
真正的富足不只是賺錢
還要有一個健康的身體
才能好好生活
愛自己是你能給自己
最珍貴的禮物
對
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同我推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
只要花兩杯咖啡的錢喔
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦